hey guys uh Greg here so um I just I was
I just heard this news like a half hour
ago um I was going to go exercise and I
was in my car and I got a text message
about
this and I've been sort of just
processing this you I mean from the
whatever the title of this is uh yeah
Matthew Perry has uh apparently died at
the age of 54 years old and there's no
looking more into it of what led to this
um apparent
drowning
and needless to say I'm uh pretty messed
up about it at the moment and I just
wanted to say a few things to remember
him in case you guys don't know whoever
watching this channel for a while I've
stated many times i' I've even worn
Matthew Perry on my shirt several times
on this channel is uh friends is my
all-time favorite show I've obsessively
watched it many many times rewatched it
and you know when I was like a little
kid I realized very early on uh that I
was an extremely depressed child there's
no other way to put it I knew it like I
was had a lot of severe depression uh I
was born in 1990 and
friends was a show that I really credit
for helping to shape a lot of my
personality you know and but it was
mainly Chandler like there are two
personalities I credit for helping to
shape my personality and that was Conan
O'Brien and Chandler Bing because I saw
that there was a way as a coping
mechanism especially for Chandler to use
humor especially with like going to
school and be able to socialize with
people I I naturally adopted it and like
the self-deprecating side as well and so
this is a a a real life tragedy that is
it's so it just feels silly it sounds it
sounds kind of goofy to say because like
I I obviously never met this guy
I've never even seen him in person um
but I really feel like this man helped
save my life when I was a kid like a lot
and and uh you know I even love in his
other work the like the whole nine yards
uh whole 10 yards I even really liked to
watch both of them uh Le second where I
saw in theaters I love Fools Rush In
growing up and I even watched Studio 60
uh because of him because he was the
reason I watched that
show I didn't even know who Aon sorin
was at the time that was the reason I
watched that show even seeing him as 17
again and other things I like his Odd
Couple show and yeah I I I really like
his a lot of his personal life and
public like stuff has you know really
been on the Forefront and on display and
a lot of his real life struggles but I
really feel like he brought a lot of joy
to um a lot of people and especially in
my
life I really feel like he helped shape
me a lot and as goofy as it sounds
because he was just some guy on TV for
me yeah the dude actually meant a lot
more to me than just that and uh I just
wanted to say uh thank you for
everything you brought us and thank you
for helping save my life when I was a
kid and uh hope you're in a better place
now and if the comments can just like
it' be cool just uh share some love and
you know the rency everything you can
remember about this guy yeah this feels
weird because like like I said I don't
know the
guy uh but it definitely definitely made
an impact on me and I don't feel like
I'd be here
today I'm going to just cut it off right
here but yeah I just I did want to say
something to remember him because he was
a big shining light of my
life that's all share down like what you
love most about it like even when I was
like pacing around outside you know it's
like kind of naturally just will think
of jokes in like uncomfortable moments
and uh when I shouldn't be thinking of
jokes I know a lot of that comes from
Chandler just like making jokes at the
most inappropriate times and just
thinking about
like how I was feeling I was facing
around this stupid out loud to myself I
was like could could I be any more sad
right now like that kind of thinking is
H yeah
um anyway all right I'm I'm done um rest
in peace Matthew Perry I hope uh his
friends and family are um doing okay
right now and please share in the
comments what you love most about him
and uh if you helped shape you at all
too growing up in the
90s